some advice for two 60 year old
entrepreneurs 16 I mean the only the
only thing I think maps for every 16
year old entrepreneur is patients like
it like the biggest mistake of 16 year
old entrepreneurs make is they want
things to happen too soon you have so
much time I mean it's insane to me to
think about how much time you actually
have if you doubled your age you would
still be 8 years younger than me you
know what I mean and when you think
about it that way you have so much time
so I think the biggest thing I would
tell you is use your advantages so you
don't have experience B of time what
that means is put yourself in a position
where you're learning and leveraging now
not cashing in
you know don't don't you don't need the
money yet you don't need the fame yet
you know build the foundational pieces
that will make you successful
be patient spend time around people that
have been successful go look at
different things you can commit to seven
years of just learning and still be
young as [ __ ] you know you've taught
time as your asset so patience great
awesome in real